Hi, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys.
Dan's very excited today.
This is actually, you
wanted to do this one.
You saw a video on the internet
of a guy spinning wire wool.
Yeah, fireworks, sort of thing.
Looks like a Catherine
wheel, except homemade.
Except you're the wheel.
Yeah, exactly, we got some wire wool here,
very fine stuff, the zero,
zero, zero, zero grade.
And, you sort of puff it out,
attach it to some wires, spin it around
while it is on fire, and because
of the air that's all rushing through it,
it sort of just goes...
Almost took my eye out
with that there, almost.
I'm a bit worried about,
it's going to be showering
sparks in every direction.
Really hot sparks as well.
Let's dumper down the grass,
because, you know, the grass looks good.
So, you've got a fire marshal there, yeah?
Alright good.
What was that?
Sorry I can't hear you
cause you're not real.
Shut up.
So we usually don't film
this late in the day.
The sun is almost completely,
you know, off the ground.
But we want the darkness for this one,
cause we want the fire
to be the only light.
So as soon as it goes.
It's going now.
Just go mental with it, yeah.
Wow!
Flippen heck.
Okay hold on, hold it
still, okay go for it.
Well Dan, I think that was
a majestic looking video.
Ah, it's so pretty.
We experimented with a
lot of different stuff,
like wide open shutter, lower flame rates
actually as well, just
to get the light on you.
I thought it looked tremendous,
it was like a little music video going on.
I burned you.
Yeah, at one point you splashed
me with about 500 sparks in the face.
We did enjoy that.
And neck.
No, it was good fun.
Ah, hot.
My favorite part of the video in fact.
So this is about to go out.
So, do feel free to follow us on Twitter,
buy a shirt and subscribe
to The Slow Mo Guys.
It's almost like what's the
stuff in Mindcraft called
that lights up?
Glow stone?
Glow stone, yes it's
almost like that, isn't it?
Glow stone.
Cool, see you next time.
Goodnight.
Do a little whirl.
Oh god!
It's burning.
What did we expect?
I don't know.
Oh god, just want to say a big thank you
to Audible for sponsoring this video.
It's a great service, they've got over
180 thousand audio books available
from things like Sci-Fi, fantasy
to business and biography.
At the minute I'm listening
to The Martian by Andy Weir.
If you like the movie, you should
definitely listen to the book.
There's no better way to
get involved in the story,
it's really sort of, it's
much emotional then the film,
cause you can connect to
the characters, it's a book.
Yeah I'd say it's out of this world.
What?
Look, just click on the link below
or at audible.com/slowmo
and get a free trail,
you'll love it.